und wir sprechen über den mann der immer
noch irgendwo ganz oben in den bergen es
immer noch kein lebenszeichen vom
bergsteiger drama das sich seit tagen
bei berchtesgaden abspielt ganz genau
bei ramsau am 2600 meter hohen
hochkalter ja da ist er hoch geklettert
24 jahre alt julian p aus niedersachsen
komplett alleine hier sehen wir ihn und
dann kam plötzlich der wintereinbruch
und das hat ihn total überrascht damit
hat er nicht gerechnet ein notruf konnte
er noch absetzen vom handy das war am
samstag aber seitdem hört man von ihm
von julian nichts
alleine verletzt in den bergen im
schneesturm in den alpen seit samstag
wird ein 24 jähriger niedersachse am
hochkalter in den berchtesgadener alpen
vermisst schnee eiseskälte alleine in
den bergen der bergsteiger war bei
widrigsten verhältnissen zu der tour auf
den rund 2600 meter hohen hochkalter
aufgebrochen er selbst hatte noch einen
notruf am nachmittag abgesetzt nachdem
er im schnee auf etwa 2.500 höhenmetern
abgerutscht war seit diesem zeitpunkt
läuft eine aufwändige vermisstensuche
einsatzkräfte sind zu fuß im gelände
unterwegs immer wieder steigen
rettungshubschrauber auf sofern es das
wetter zulässt doch vom 24-jährigen
weiterhin keine spur
namen haben leider so aus dem zug ein
satz der heute fortgesetzt würde keine
weiteren erkenntnisse eigentlich ziehen
können das einzige man kann auf kommt
von der ausrüstung bis hier bisher
stärker ins detail dargestellt hat
darauf rückschlüsse ziehen was er dabei
gehabt hat und was uns vielleicht die
hoffnung gibt dass man vielleicht doch
ein einsatz mit einer technischen
unterstützung sprich rekord gerät
gewisse erfolgschancen oder traum sieht
die erfolgschancen somit etwas erhöht
aufgrund der wetterverhältnisse in der
gipfelregion können bei diesen
sichtverhältnissen keine einsatzkräfte
hinauf geschickt werden temperaturen bei
minus sechs grad
schneefalls stark regen wind und nebel
die einsatzkräfte von bergwacht und
polizei sind in bereitschaft und werden
versuchen sobald es das wetter und die
sichtverhältnisse zu lassen sowohl zu
fuß als auch mit den hubschraubern und
weiteren einsatzmitteln die suche
fortzusetzen
dezember worten was uns im herbst es
noch erwartet wie viel schnee noch mal
weggeht und wir die chance habe im laufe
der woche noch einmal der suche zu
starten
entsprechende flugblätter und auch
wetter bei dem wir die einsatzkräfte
einfach ins gelände schicken können dass
die noch mal suchen
ansonsten kannst durchaus im bereich des
möglichen sein dass wir erst im frühjahr
dann diese person finden das gerät riss
sein als zuletzt und ich haben schon
wunder erlebt aber sicher lese ich jetzt
seine eigenen 8 das ist die nächste
nacht es wird nicht warm also bis
dienstag ist keine wirkliche
verbesserung vorhergesagt es bleibt kalt
also da müsste er schon riesen glück
haben vielleicht ein gutes loch gefunden
haben wo er sich jetzt einfach noch
aufhalten kann aber
die chancen
aber nicht
das wetter und der stoffe berger
schweren die arbeit der retter die
hoffnung zu diesem albtraum ein gutes
ende zu finden bleiben groß der 24
jährige vermisste bleibt weiterhin
alleine im schnee und der kälte in den
bergen
[Musik]